so Jacob we're here for the premiere of
little accident tell me a little bit
about your role in the film
I play Owen who is he's kind of in a
hard place his dad just passed away and
he's having to take care of his family
so he's got a lot of stress on him you
know the world of the weight of the
world on his shoulders so I mean you
know he's normal kid that's just had all
this stuff happy he just doesn't know
how to take it how did you come across
the role they I read the script and I
thought it was an amazing script I mean
it was written so great and we met Sarah
I actually met her on the phone with
first time and she was like the nicest
sweetest person I've ever met I'm like
I've got to work on this it's gonna be
great people so you know I went after it
got it and so excited I did tell me
about some of your co-stars to film as
well you've got this with banks and
their free time haven't you
yeah Elizabeth Banks Boyd Holbrook Josh
Lucas they were all amazing I mean they
are just the funnest people to work with
they all cut up and joke and it's just
it's amazingly fun how does it compare
to making modes it was a smaller budget
and everybody was I mean it was like I
said it was a smaller budget a little
more stressful but everybody had a great
time we were all a big family so it was
great what can we look forward to three
nights I'm doing a TV show right now on
FX called justified so that's it'll be
the next thing you can see me in what
kind of role to be looking at in that
being a southern troublemaker imagine
that you could do anything else next
work with anyone else any kind of roles
that you look out for I would love to do
a comedy I'd love to do a comedy yeah
any actors of directors you'd like to
work with in future all of them I'm up
for meeting anybody and working with
anybody so lots to look for the premiere
tonight I'm sure you have a great time
thank you
you